hey
this is not halfway
i did the math i had to drive
montclair would have been closer so you
have to buy lunch
what are you doing
i just
i can't wait
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
hello jacob
hames
what are you doing here why aren't you
out looking for the belt you and i both
know the belt never left the precinct i
don't know that nobody knows that i kept
thinking how did anyone swap my key and
then it hit me they didn't they swapped
the safe one of the handmaids i'm
assuming fake charles took my safe and
then of amy deposited a look-alike
where did you give fake charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of financial freedom
i invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay
so while we all tried to figure out who
had the real key fake charles broke into
the safe removed the tracker and led
terry in the whole squad on a wild goose
chase my only question is which box is
the belt in well good luck figuring it
out because the clock is tick tick
tocking it's that one no the dust
pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors
you see jake i'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you're just plain
boring again weird take on our very
loving relationship and it's midnight so
i guess i'm an amazing human slash
genius yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that they're built why
oh no what does it say
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise
i'm so confused i don't know what's
happening right now i'm so confused i
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape oh my god i'm
shaking i'm definitely gonna cry title
of your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist if
this is part of the heist i will dump
you so hard no please look it's really
happening okay it's not part of the
heist i promise this is
who you are i love how beautiful you are
i love your face and i love your butt i
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on i love how much you
pretend to like die hard i like the
second one you don't have to okay yeah
you're
kind and you're funny and you're the
best person i know and
the best detective
also for reals i love your butt i love
yours too gross
amy santiago
will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you
i love you so much hey jerkos this
little [ __ ] escaped so that ought to
teach
did you just mm-hmm and did you say
well my boyfriend might not be moving
back for a while so i have to back out
just wanted to look at it one more time
you know i can't give you your deposit
back i know
and there's a 300 all right martha i get
it
actually is there a way i could put down
like a
hey hey
you know you were coming back here oh
what are you doing
oh my god what are you doing
i'm thinking about my future
i am deeply
ridiculously
in love with you and above everything
else i just i
i want to be with you forever
so leslie knope
wait wait
okay just
i need to remember this sure give me a
second
leslie no no no hold on just i need
another second please
i need to remember
every
little thing
about how perfect my life is right now
at this exact moment
okay you good yeah okay i'm good
leslie knope
yes
marry me oh yeah okay
so this is one of my favorite places in
the world why this is where toby
announced that he was going to costa
rica
it's the happiest day of my life
until the day you came to replace him
let's go in here
and this is where we first kissed
i remember
and this is where we first made love
remember what i tried there michael
through these blinds
is where i first saw you and you had all
these boxes and i thought you were the
prettiest mover i'd ever seen
and i was sitting at this desk
when i called you to tell you that i had
herpes and that i was still in love with
you and you said that it was over and
that you didn't love me
and thank goodness none of that was true
including the herpes ingrown hair
right in here
this
is where we co-ran our first meeting
remember obesity awareness mm-hmm saved
a lot of lives that day that's where you
first met michael clump oh i say i say i
sit on you
and right over there that's where you
realize that meredith was prostituting
herself for outback steak and i will
never forget that you had the cutest
look on your face because you couldn't
believe it you thought it was so wrong
and over here what happened here well
nothing
nothing really i would just find an
excuse to come here
so i could stare at you through that
window
this is what i do
nice
let's go in here
hi guys
this is where our love faces its
toughest test
after this it's just smooth sailing for
the rest of our lives
holly
will you marry me
no
marry me holly
no
that guy's got more than he can handle
as it is will you marry me
no
that marriage would be a sham will you
marry me no easy no will you marry me no
that would be hot i would pay to see
that will you marry me holly
no only one that i was kind of worried
about
oh
this is where i fell in love with you
and this is where i ask you to marry me
it started
[Laughter]
polly flax
marrying me will you be
your wife be coming
[Applause]
you know like when jim proposed he just
he got down on one knee and he told me
that he loved me and he asked me to
marry him and it was perfect where was
that
at a gas station
the gas station well it was when she was
working in new york so it was halfway
between both of us that must have been a
surprise
when
at the gas station you proposed
no it was really it was really sweet
it was raining and oh hey yeah you
didn't say that the weather was bad that
sounds
perfect
you